hello welcome to this video playing I am
mad man no name okay so let's see going
for the tomorrow which is saying so
somewhat oh one of those lights I have
no idea here whoa this has come into
fashion recently Queen to f3 and yeah so
it's always hard for me to kind of
believe that this Queen trade can be
something for white and the long run but
ok pliko play it and quite successfully
and ok here is an energy for an option
here let's see when you cannot move the
bishop and nights in 693 looks strange
96 93 94 set playable you kind of Hastur
fania so now I could take f1 form for
two bishops against two nights but in a
position where the bishops are not doing
that much I can go back to G for losing
losing time ok I think I'd go for that
I'm I'm not one hundred percent
convenience that this is such so
fantastic I mean I'm a huge bishop am
going but it's not that easy at the
moment to coordinate this I have no
development absolutely no development
and it shouldn't be underestimated that
with HT hg three the H fried is open so
sometimes there are things like [ __ ] age
5 or something he has basically a full
development for example you move like a
b5 which looks generally desirable it's
not that easy here because of
potentially a forward and I still think
I have to do it I don't see how else i
get my c8 bishop in the game
ok so I play Bishop d7 yeah so he wants
to probably fix my age ponyo with g5
that's it but g5f / should be seven so
that that's not going to work at all at
the moment currently I have this idea to
go B form like be four night f4 Bishop
takes rook takes rook c2 and then rook
see one is a threat now this should be
it should be very good for black but
it's still again I don't think it's all
a tease iam
maybe just be four and 75 later like be
four night a for Bishop e7 and then 75
it could also be an idea it's difficult
for white to play this position so I
understand why it's not moving tries to
trust to figure it out or it's just a
ping issue I don't I don't think so now
it looks like it's connected a three so
um stopping before for the moment so
what to do one idea is to play Bishop to
f6 and potentially rooks you form can
also do but should be six and then Roxy
form but I actually like this a little
bit more it also makes g5 impossible if
he goes 'if i have a look like f6
okay now there's no pin anyone is going
up with the king
so this was my idea put it here and then
look-see for next maybe he tries for me
and for f4 sorry voice is failing me f4f
g6 it's luke c5 a move or not maybe just
g6 yeah it's pushing back this is this
is ok and now whoopsie for and double
something like that that would be good
yeah yeah this is good he cannot go five
now at f5 is mostly giving me square so
those pawns are not dangerous okay so so
d5 let's go d 5
okay yes I thought that defy have it
this is the this is this truck so he has
saw some kind of blockade here quite
resigned i just spent also lots of time
down yeah okay this is this opening on
this Queen f3 ideas is very interesting
but probably that's too early I think
probably has to Castle first or
something like that this I don't really
believe with the two bishops it should
be it should be very good for black I
kind of I think I played it okay at
first I'm okay with all this I think
here my position is very nice but the d5
was was wrong at least them yeah
probably not the best rookie eight was
what's good here okay going for counter
counter check or something check this I
have that check and window win the peace
I came yeah maybe blended that one but
he would lose on time anyway yeah I
spent spent a bit bit too much time yeah
this I think him he has to play
differently here probably castles long
looks good
it is this interesting and it it's very
quick development with the Queen on f3
and the Queen quite often has some
interesting ideas there on the
third-ranked some interesting line for
white ok guys thanks for watching